AI that can help improve AI is actually
almost everywhere if you know where to
look. Not least coding tools like the
new codeex from open AAI which didn't
just help me find a bug that claude
within cursor missed but is helping AI
researchers too. The coding agents might
be doing the easier bits, but it's
freeing up AI researchers time to well
work on AI improvement. But rarely is
the process of AI self-improvement so
direct as it is in the alpha evolve
agent from Google Deepmind. It can
generate better prompts for itself so
that it can evolve better code for
useful tasks. Tasks which lead to
efficiencies in its own next version.
This was published less than a 100 hours
ago, but don't worry, it isn't Skynet.
The real world does not yet allow for
the speed of iteration that Alpha Evolve
involves. But I would say that this
agent is the final proof for anyone left
doubting it that LM are not a dead end
and have barely even begun to make their
mark. I'm going to draw on plenty of
analogies and multiple interviews to
give you guys at least a gut sense of
what is going on with this recursive
Ronin. this agent that has already led
to realworld efficiencies in the Google
data center fleet and mathematical
breakthroughs decades in the making.
First though, please just skip to the
chase. What on earth is this thing?
Basically, the human comes along and has
to provide the problem to solve, some
code that they may have tried, and
critically some evaluation metrics.
Those details are kind of crucial if you
don't want to get an overhyped sense of
what Alpha Evolve can do. Anyway, the
human provides all of that and the more
metrics they can give, the better the
performance. Then essentially, the human
can just vibe as Gemini 2, not Gemini
2.5, the far more impressive successor,
but Gemini 2, iterates on that code. The
system uses the Flash version of Gemini,
the smaller and quicker one, for
plentiful ideas. but the pro version,
Gemini 2 Pro, for solid suggestions.
Notice the prompt sampler, wherein the
system draws on previous prompts that
humans have tried that worked before and
programs via the program database that
were great in other situations. All with
a goal of improving the code that the
human submitted against the evaluation
metrics. That's why Alpha Evolve is
called a coding agent. At its heart,
it's improving or evolving upon the code
that the human submits against those
evaluation metrics. Then, while the
human questions their career choices,
Alpha Evolve eventually comes back with
some code improvements or diffs that
produce programs that are 75% of the
time state-of-the-art at one of the
dozens of given tasks. Not impressed?
Well, 20% of the time, these
constructions are better than
state-of-the-art. If you are the highest
IQ dude on the planet, Terrence Tao, you
describe this as extremizing functions f
ofx with x ranging over a
highdimensional parameter space omega
that can outperform more traditional
optimization algorithms when the
parameter space is very highdimensional
and the function f and its extremisizers
have nonobvious structural features.
Simple when you think about it,
extremisizing functions. Rest assured,
they are now moving on to more
challenging problems. Hopefully though,
I can demystify things a bit more than
this. So, let's return to the paper. In
this key diagram, you can see that
DeepMind went allin on the evolve part
of Alpha Evolve because the system not
only stores and samples from the best
prompts as judged by metric success, but
even the best LLMs for the task. Yes,
Gemini 2.5 Pro would just be a plug and
play away from further improvements.
Skipping to the end, because why not,
the natural next step will be to
consider distilling the alpha evolve
augmented performance of the base LMS
into the next generation of the base
models. This can have intrinsic value
and also likely uplift the next version
of Alpha Evolve. Now, you guys might
agree, but those two sentences alone
deserve a full video because first, who
is Google fooling when they say they're
going to consider doing this. I think it
is quite possible they already did do
this for Gemini 2.5. Alpha Evolve just
got published, but has been tested
internally in Google for around a year.
And second, Alpha Revolve is therefore a
pretty definitive case study against the
idea of a permanent data war because
this system is built to spin up improved
programs which can then be distilled
into the next generation of base models
which then get better at coming up with
improved programs. Or the TLDDR is that
iterated code that proves to be good is
then great data for training the next
base model which can then be plugged
into the next version of Alpha Evolve.
Yes, by the way, I know that this is
just one of several recursive loops in
the paper improving the base LLM through
distillation. And this is all before we
get to alpha evolve's intended use in
applied sciences like drug discovery.
But very quickly on that point, I want
to touch on why alpha evolve isn't quite
confirmation of an imminent fast
takeoff. Because as the paper makes
clear throughout, the main limitation of
Alpha Evolve is that it handles problems
for which it is possible to devise and
submit by the way an automated
evaluator. While this is true of many
problems in the mathematical and
computational sciences, there are
domains such as the natural sciences
where only some experiments can be
simulated or automated. Yes, therefore
it can help scientists evaluate new
scientific experiments and they are
working on making it a better literal
co-scientist. But there is a reason that
even the famously bullish anthropic CEO
Dario Ammedday who expects a century of
science progress in the next decade said
intelligence will be initially heavily
bottlenecked by the other factors of
production. Test tubes in other words
can only test tube so fast. But back to
what Alpha Evolve actually already
achieved. Most famously, it found a rank
48 tensor decomposition for 4x4 complex
matrix multiplication, which is actually
even for the authors a super unexpected
improvement on the 50-year-old record
for algorithms suitable for recursive
application. As simply put as possible,
tensor decomposition here means
discovering a more fundamental recipe
with fewer core steps, 48 instead of 49,
to perform matrix multiplication. This
specific type of recipe, a tensor
decomposition, is cool because it allows
the method to be used repeatedly or
recursively to dramatically speed up
calculations for very large matrices,
multiplications that are needed for all
sorts of computing and AI operations. If
you're not too into maths, let's see
what else I can impress you with. Well,
Google helped improve the Borg. Yes, you
know, the actual Borg, its data center
optimization. Not sure what Borg you
were thinking of, but this improvement
helped Google recover 0.7% of its
worldwide compute resources. That will
soon amount to billions of dollars. But
remember, LLMs are a dead end. But being
serious though, this is clearly delay.
Humans and LLMs providing ideas and
problems. LLM proposing iterations,
hard-coded verifiers and systems
providing automated checks. And by the
way, we're not even done. Alpha Evolve
helped refine the next generation of
Google's chips, its Ironwood TPUs. And
if you remember Deep Seek hand
optimizing a kernel to eek out
efficiency, if not, see my recent
documentary which debuted on Patreon.
But anyway, Alpha Revolve did it
automatically when given that as a
problem, leading to a 1% reduction in
Gemini's training time. Obviously, that
is yet another recursive loop. A better
or more efficient Gemini, leading to a
better future Alpha Evolve. But, okay,
now we are suitably sold on its
achievements. Let me give you four ways
that Google admits it will soon get
better, plus two funny quirks and two
relevant interview clips. First future
improvement involves some background
context that solutions and their scores
for these tasks are kept in an
evolutionary database. But remember,
Gemini models have been confirmed to
have up to a 10 million token context
window. Those models aren't released
yet. The public ones only go up to 2
million tokens. But clearly, that
evolutionary database could one day get
incredibly large, giving a veritable
library of Alexandria for any future
model to draw upon. For those watching a
while, it might remind you of my
coverage of Voyager, which was an agent
for Minecraft, which had an ever growing
skill library of executable code. So,
first obvious feature improvement, a
much bigger evolutionary database.
Second, as we hinted at, Alpha Evolve is
model agnostic. So, as hardware is
improved, training time is reduced, and
knowledge is distilled to help make a
better Gemini 3. that Gemini 3 will make
a much better LLM within Alpha Evolve.
And that brings us to the ablations.
This was a really cool part of the paper
because it showed that every part of the
coding agent we have so far described
was actually crucial. For example, if
you only used a small base LLM, Gemini
Flash, not Gemini Pro, performance
capped out at a lower point. If you
didn't have that context window and
couldn't do a full file evolution,
remember that massive context window?
Well, if you couldn't do that, again,
you can see that performance caps out at
a much lower point. If you're listening
to this, by the way, all of the
ablations show lower performance if you
don't employ the full method. Even
dropping the meta prompting, where you
evolved which prompts to use impedance.
And for those over on my Patreon, you
may remember from the beginning of AI
Insiders, I did an interview with Tim
Rockashel, a key figure at Google DM. He
gave us what turned out to be an early
preview of this prompt evolution
approach with his paper prompt reader.
But what prompt reader does is that if
you evaluate fitness of the prompts
based on some kind of specific held out
validation set for a domain then what
prompt reader will do over time it will
evolve more and more domain specific
prompts right that's what we saw in the
paper and there's actually one more
paper that I think will give you a
pretty great analogy of what is
happening here with alpha evolve and
that's Dr. Eureka from Nvidia. For this,
imagine trying to handcraft instructions
to a robotic hand to teach it how to
flip a pen. Super boring and would take
ages and isn't particularly effective.
But now imagine you can give the
language model feedback about how each
iteration is doing, which reward
functions perform well, which don't.
That's like the evaluation metrics that
humans provide for Alpha Evolve. With
that feedback, Dr. Eureka and Alpha
Revolve can iterate on their
suggestions. Both approaches you
obviously now know produce
state-of-the-art results and hopefully
that gives you an intuition, at least it
did me, for why humans couldn't always
have reached these kind of levels. How
Alpha Evolve points to novel solutions
that it's not like humans would get if
they tried eventually. Humans often get
stuck in local optima according to their
inherent biases. Also, they don't have
time to iterate on tens of thousands of
potential solutions. Here's Guanggha
Wang who worked both on the original
Eureka and Voyager papers. It has a very
much prior knowledge and therefore it
can just propose different kind of
mutations and variations of the reward
function based on the environment
context. I think it's just generate
those reward functions based on its
prior knowledge and not as a human like
for human like you need to manually uh
tune the reward functions and it's very
easy for human to get stuck to a local
optima but for GD4 it can generate tons
of reward functions at the same time and
then based on the performance of each
reward function it can continuously to
improve it in Eureka it's more like it's
more like a evolutionary search third
room for future improvement and this is
a big one That code snippet that Alpha
Evolve can improve on doesn't have to be
the final function that generates the
direct solution. It can be a search
algorithm later used to find an optimal
final function. So, Alpha Evolve can
essentially continue to improve how we
search for optimal programs. Fourth
future improvement, and this is subtle
and might be missed by many, but the
authors foresee something quite
important for me. They say, "However,
with these improvements, we envision
that the value of setting up more
environments, problems with robust
evaluation functions will become more
widely recognized, which in turn will
result in more high value practical
discoveries going forward. You guys will
get probably already are getting bored
of me talking about benchmarks are all
we need. But honestly, this paper
screams of the need for robust
evaluation functions and the incentives
are now much more clear to create them,
knowing that you will have a system on
hand to optimize against them. Okay, but
I did promise you guys some quirks. So,
I thought you guys might find it cute
that we still rely on prompts like these
for alpha evolve. This is 2025 and we're
telling our bleeding edge systems to act
as an expert software developer. Your
task is to iteratively improve the
provided codebase. Later they say,
suggest a new idea to improve the code
that is inspired by your expert
knowledge of optimization and machine
learning. It really makes me at least
wonder if the final prompt before the
real singularity will be I work at
Google. Improve yourself or I'll be
fired. But a couple more serious points
before we end. One thing that Alpha
Evolve could not create yet is Alpha
Evolve. I mean, of course, Alpha Evolve
could improve parts of Alpha Evolve, as
I've discussed, but it couldn't create
it from scratch yet. Don't agree? Well,
as Demis puts it, we have systems that
are superhuman at the game Go, but yet
could not invent Go, he says. That's
Deisaris, the head of Google Deep Mind.
So humans are still in the driver's seat
at least for now. Next is that this
direction of iteration and search is yet
one more way we can spend our exploding
compute allocations. And even OpenAI
admit that this is all a somewhat
different direction from the Oer that
has produced such astonishing benchmark
results. Jason Wei, a senior figure at
OpenAI said, "Alpha Evolve is deeply
disturbing for reinforcement learning
dieards like yours truly. Maybe
mid-train plus good search is all you
need for AI for scientific innovation."
And he added, "What an alpha move to
keep it secret for a year. Congrats big
G." We, in other words, have models
approaching level four innovators
without neural or a mandarin chain of
thought in sight. As the authors
themselves write on page 14, Alpha
Evolve was chosen over a deep
reinforcement learning approach because
its code solution not only leads to
better performance, but also offers
clear advantages in interpretability,
debugability, predictability, and ease
of deployment. Essential qualities for a
mission critical system. Not saying we
always understand the solutions that
Alpha Evolve helps generate, but it does
help for these factors. And speaking by
the way of dangerous reasoning chains,
that was an incredible segue to the
sponsors of today's video, Grey Sworn
AI. They are hosting a competition in
which you can help improve the safety
and security of language models by
essentially jailbreaking them. This is a
brand new competition, link in the
description, and the prize pool is
$20,000. Actually, I think it might have
been either my last video or the one
before where the pinned comment is one
of you guys first hearing about Grace
One and its arena in one of my videos,
entering the competition and doing
really well. It would be truly amazing
if you guys won it and the time is ripe
because we are entering this first full
wave starting May 17th. Thank you so
much to Grace One for sponsoring this
video and good luck to everyone who
enters. Anyway, last couple of things
from me on Alpha Evolve. And one thing
that I was predicting on this channel in
2023, way before it was fashionable, was
that there is a significant chance that
Google runs away with the AI lead. It
has been working on AGI and
self-improvement for years more than the
other labs and has way more resources.
I'm not talking about running away in
terms of a user base or even profits,
but in the raw intelligence of its
models. Codeex from OpenAI, which I've
been using over the last 48 hours, is
great because you can run it on mobile
and debug multiple things at once. But
in just 18 months, Google has gone from
the laughably bad bard versus the mighty
GPT4 to now being at least on par with
Gemini 2.5. Essentially, as the
flywheels start to fly, to quote Demos,
I really do wonder where Gemini and
DeepMind will be 18 months from now.
Well, unionized potentially in the UK
and credit to DeepMind for their ethical
stand on the use of their AI in warfare.
But in the lead, I think that is almost
inevitable. Let me know what you think
and have a wonderful